h
lag meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer runde
minecraft mario kart bzw minecraft to go
kart racer so ich dachte eigentlich
immer schneiden aber es geht schon in
sechs sekunden los zusammen mit dem
peterle hallo hey leute was geht wir
werden das sehen und wir haben das auch
schon bei peter rauf auf den kanal
gebracht das heißt auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen und es gibt verschiedene
items und so ich erkläre das einfach mal
während dem spiel also wir haben mehrere
mario kart mäßige strecken und auch die
mutter sich ja nicht mehr
ja okay die steuerung ist echt ein
bisschen charakter aber mannheims und
das ein eigenes text schon der helm und
so ich bin ja erst ab zweiter erster ich
verstehe dass wir das mal wechseln kann
was lange darf ich fahrrad voll verwirrt
gelangen
hay group freunde das ist halt die sache
man weiß nie wirklich wo man lang muss
oder was die steuer oder die steuerung
ein bisschen komisch und so aber es
macht megaspaß richtig ausgeglichen
also da hatte ich ihn das erste rennen
gewonnen und er das zweite ganz knapp an
fotofinish einfach ja gut aber du bist
jetzt wo bist du so weit abgeschlagen
aber jetzt wahrscheinlich einen eigenen
preis gefahren bin wahrscheinlich
es gibt ja auch so areal dadurch
bekommen ja ich bin extra die ganze
terrasse bist einfach vor mir man warte
komm ich zeig dir meine abkürzung
du musst irgendwie es gibt die
möglichkeit freuen ich versuche ich das
jetzt mal zu zeigen wenn man schiff
drückt und dann hier so rum da so klappt
bei mir so ein bisschen heißt man ja ok
hat für den moment man langsam aber
danach klappt das ganze ist auf jeden
fall schillig ok ja das ist das problem
und zwar wenn man manchmal eben rein
fährt dann ist man wieder im normalen
modus und aber ich möchte ganz 5 modus
fahren weil das einfach nein nein
glaubens alle via kann bei mir ich will
dich da hinten im schneeball treffen
aber ich sehe mir angekommen weil ich
war so wieder zu driften um die kurve
naja ich weiß nicht ob das so viel
bringt mit dem griff zum überholen oder
was eigentlich nicht ich fand ich war
diesmal entlang way was als ob als ob
konzentriert ich bin 80 damit im zweiten
rennen und zwar auf welcher mit befinden
wir uns gerade canyon canyon und ihr
seht schon vorne da hinten über also ihr
bergs gebirge was erzgebirge nicht
richtig sein team und alle weg zum
schwert oder so da ist am schild geht's
denn hier lang ich glaube ohne die
andere weiß ich wieder nicht wo's
langgeht
nein nein fand nicht gegen den bär
ob du kleiner bühne die man kriegt ein
schneeball von hinten ab black hat für
den aufgelegt ja gut ich dachte schon
jetzt hier in dem sie zudem schmeckt er
ich bin neunter ich könnte heulen auch
man will und kakteen habe stern ich am
stern glaube ich weil ich die ganze zeit
schneller bin als alle anderen unserem
komischen schild um mich herum habe und
da bin ich schon wieder dritter jetzt so
schwer
walter ich verstehe diese noch dabei
muss das einfach viel öfter spielen
damit man die kompletten runden mal
versteht wo man genau lang fahren muss
ja nicht gleich jetzt etwas schon mal
beim schneeball hier ab und wieder
evogene für hat die fische wieder mepha
was ist das denn gewartet wie stark die
krasseste aufholjagd aller zeiten freuen
kommt die aufgabe
jahrhunderts auf der einer genauen
banane hingesetzt hat das echt
demoversion der wand fest
wie soll ich das denn schaffen ich bin
wartet doch mal dann vor kompletter ich
bin vater kommt komplett in der hand so
knapp an den dran alter ja neulich und
wörter geworden als alter alten einfach
siebter zehn sekunden ich hoffe ich
schaffe es überhaupt noch ins ziel da zu
eurem ziel was für ein scheißrennen
dieses spiel mag mich einfach nicht ist
einfach die maps noch nicht richtig
kennt dann ist es mega shadow einfach
manchmal nicht weiß wo es langgeht
wurden von chip.de
wussten die siegerehrung irgendwo zu
schauen oder so es gab gar keine alter
mann
naja gut freund ich hoffe es hat euch
trotzdem gefallen wenn ihr ein richtiges
fotofinish sehen wollt dann schaut auf
jeden fall bei peters ohne vorbei peters
in der beschreibung oben verlinkt da
haben wir richtig wirklich das war
adrenalin pur auf der zielgeraden das
war richtig krass wenn ihr davon mehr
sehen wollen würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und dann sehen wir uns
eventuell einer weiteren folge wieder
ist da